this man
diy engineers superhero gadgets from his
garage
my name is jake laser and i'm the real
life tony stark at this point i've done
over 500 projects of pretty much every
imaginable superhero gadget
having spent countless hours over the
last nine years in his garage workshop
jake has taken green goblin's glider
iron man's briefcase suit and dozens of
other devices from the realm of
make-believe into a functioning reality
the idea of going beyond what normal
humans can do is really relatable
excitement that you get and that like
curiosity and a little bit of mystery as
well it's all it's all wrapped up in
there
[Music]
i mean every kid loves superhero movies
so i've loved superheroes my entire life
at this point i just love that idea of
doing cool stuff like superhuman
abilities you know like flying walking
on water running really fast all of this
stuff i think my favorite build to date
is probably the spider-man wall climbers
it was a lot of work but i sort of had a
vision and saw it through and it like
really worked well i was able to climb a
14-story skyscraper and it was amazing
it was the most fun thing i've ever done
spider-man out
and he's made it his career jake spends
his days filming himself making these
devices and then films them in action he
wants to share his enthusiasm and
passion for the world of comic books and
hopefully inspire online audiences to
try to make fictional greatness into a
reality in my videos i like to show the
entire process and it's mostly me
failing like 85 90 of the video is okay
we tried this it doesn't work move on to
the next thing that didn't work either
but we got closer and then that just
makes the end of the video so much
better when it does work
for every finished piece there are many
steps of invention along the way even
now jake has projects in the works that
don't quite function the way he wants
okay so this is my next project this is
a device that will hopefully let me walk
on water i'm about midway through this i
first started out with like floaties on
my feet
which didn't go very well
it all sort of boils down to like a
physics problem so you really just need
to push 190 pounds downward and then in
theory i'll be able to stand on water so
i first ordered these propellers
completely waterproof brushless motors
they would go sort of on my feet like
that uh however i don't think i have
enough power to lift me out
so
what i just did is i've got this much
bigger motor connected it to this
bathroom scale
the more pressure it pushes up we can
read that right on the scale so this was
able to put out about 160 pounds of
thrust and i didn't want to go any
higher than that because i physically
couldn't hold it
so the plan now is to take this motor
and uh
mount it to my leg so to do that i first
catched up a design on the computer this
is the bare bones frame again this is
all try on there but cnc milled this you
can see sort of the
similarities with the computer screen
and what we have right here so
the way this works put my foot in like
that strap it all in there's gonna be
straps everywhere and a motor like this
is going to sit right here
and there's going to be a shaft like
this that goes through this hole
out there
and connect to
a propeller up in here
and then that should provide more than
enough thrust for me to balance and walk
run skate around on the surface of water
and also hopefully swim around
underwater sort of like aquaman
right about now i would say i've gotten
the concept i've done a fair amount of
research i've played around with a
couple different methods like the
floaties and then sort of settled on a
design that i think will work
so i'd say i'm building what i think is
the final prototype
i'd say almost all the process is trial
and error like you really don't know
what's going to happen until you do it
like you can do as much simulating on
the computer as you want but especially
in the way that i like to work i like to
make rapid prototypes first and then
test you can learn so much more from
testing than you can from theorizing and
running models and all this stuff like
if you just make a crude prototype test
it you can get so much information
these prototypes can have many
iterations but once jake figures out how
to make a gadget work he's ready to get
into the garage and build
so i'm gonna be making a captain america
shield that actually bounces off walls
and corners and stuff oh oh careful
yo good catch so to do that with through
a couple of things we need to make sure
the weight of the shield is light enough
so it flies kind of like a frisbee but
also we need to make it spring so it
bounces like a ball so to do that we're
going to be using some fiberglass this
is a basically a fiberglass ring that is
about two feet in diameter about the
size of a shield so this is what's going
to be on the outside
to keep it lightweight and also strong
we're going to be making the inside of
the shield out of some carbon fiber so
carbon fiber is naturally like very
bendy like this so to give it its
strength we're gonna be using some epoxy
there's two part epoxy mix them together
it creates a really hard substance that
you know fuses the carbon fiber together
makes it very strong to do that
i put a layer of mold release put a
layer of epoxy down then put carbon
fiber put another layer of epoxy and
then put more carbon fiber on top so
it's two layers thick which should give
us a nice balance of strength to wait
for whatever reason i never get tired of
building i just don't know what it is i
just get in a zone and
it never feels like work which is
amazing and i think engineering and
superheroes can be one and the same like
iron man
sort of proves that he's not a superhero
he doesn't have any
magical abilities but yet he's able to
go toe-to-toe with a literal god like
thor
so it looks like the epoxy is dry so i
think we can pop this carbon fiber out
and uh
get to making it so sometimes if it's
not all the way hard it won't come out
of the mold completely right but i think
we should be good with this one
there we go
yeah
all right so then on this side we have
carbon fiber
pretty hard just using standard scissors
to trim up the edges we're going to trim
it down so it fits a couple inches on
the inside of this fiberglass
so now we're left with a nice circular
carbon fiber disc
that should fit inside of the ring right
here
so now we have to coat this in uh
some
rubber
so i'm just going to add a little more
glue to the inside of this to just
completely encase this in rubber what
that's going to do is
also protect us from the fiberglass
because fiberglass will actually
splinter it's pretty nasty stuff but it
makes for good captain america shield so
no matter how long a project takes jake
can always see the final product and
drives himself towards it until the
fantastical is in his hands
so i'm just going to use the mold as
sort of a guide you don't want a
lopsided shield
yeah that's about right
and then once we've got it lined up
we're going to push it down
push up on all the rubber and get it to
connect
all right so this is pretty much ready
to go we've got uh carbon fiber rubber
and fiberglass all connected together
so the last thing we would have to do is
paint it but this is pretty much ready
to throw in a wall and it'll look really
cool
there it is
the funny thing is the first time i made
the prototype of this shield it worked
like that never happens i was thinking
about it for a while just how to
physically make this work and i was just
like no just going to throw together a
quick prototype probably did it in like
five ten minutes threw it at a wall and
it bounced directly back to me already
it was so cool and i was like oh my god
so i ran inside and showed my manager
christian and he was blown away too we
were like what is this we were like
we're holding like it's like we
discovered fire for the first time it's
like oh my god this is gonna be amazing
i think to truly sell the story of the
video and the setting we're trying to
create i think making it look movie
realistic is super important we pride
ourselves not only in like making cool
stuff but also more of that artistic eye
to try and really capture what the movie
would be in real life in a way that
pretty much anyone could do it the
functionality and realism of jake's
creations bring the magic of superheroes
alive making the worlds our comic book
icons inhabit a little closer to ours i
think that superheroes spark so much joy
for a lot of reasons actually there's
the social aspect of being able to do so
much more and having all of this
pressure i think is pretty cool and just
that out of the norm ability that
superheroes have i think is really
relatable because i think superheroes
also take a lot of inspiration from
animals
every kid looked up in the sky and seen
a bird it's like wow i want to do that
then you take a superhero put it on
screen and show it flying like i've
always wanted to do that
childhood me would be
so excited
you're thinking about
i had all these ideas all through i was
growing up and finally being able to do
them which is really cool and you know
new ideas that i never thought would be
possible i'm getting and finding a way
to do those as well
i hope people take away that impossible
might not be as impossible as they think
you know if a dude in the garage can
build stuff like this you know why can't
you i want my videos to be somewhat
relatable show that this stuff can
actually exist and sort of give people
hope that like i could actually do
something like that if i put my mind to
it and i hope in the same way to like
maybe inspire some people to uh you know
learn more about science and engineering
and stuff because that really is a
superpower on its own you have this
ability to create things that didn't
exist give yourself these abilities with
your mind like
that's to me is amazing and i hope i'm
conveying that to other people as well